c'est une journée de thérapie plus
excitantes qu'à l'habitude pour alain
les jeunes hommes de 24 ans
quadraplégique peut enfin s'amuser avec
ses jeux vidéo favoris
le nouveau programme game schengen est
une thérapie de réadaptation à l'aide de
jeux vidéo commerciaux vraiment
l'opportunité existé mais c'était plutôt
états unis et le canada wind up une
petite équipe disciplinaire en aventure
possible à l'en but à la pâte lagarde la
pression toujours moi je regarde plus le
jeu qui s'il ya des boutons ou des
mouvements un homme qui fonctionnent à
des concerts on demande à nos ingénieurs
pour nous aider à aller figuré et tous
les rêves sont permis car l'ingénieur
est en mesure d'adapter les appareils
pour chacun de ses patients debout dans
l abcès fille à un bouton pour que je
puisse le port pour que je puisse câble
est usée meddah
invaincu maintenant se mesurer à ses
ennemis qui s'ingénie sauf que je
pourrais pas jouer avant mais maintenant
avec m je peux participer avec mes amis
avec alizée avec les jeunes mariés
socialisation motricité et bénéfices
cognitifs et émotionnel les bienfaits
sont nombreux et aller se sent moins
stressé je suis pas frustré qu'un juge
ait un donc je ferme pas le jeu comme
souvent grâce à la volonté de ses
intervenants qui le suivent depuis huit
ans de rendre sa vie toujours plus
agréable
il a pu mener des études qui le pousse
aujourd'hui à aider les gens en retour à
des gens mais parce que j'ai des il me
disait que je peux pas passer plus de
trois heures comme un quart et un peu je
pourrais faire que t'es pas trop fusée
alphan manas substance pour l'instant
levé patients bénéficient du programme
engagé avec ses intervenants participent
déjà de nouvelles aventures pour le
futur dans le but d'en aider d'autres il
s'affairait radio canada
fédérer